today on the matt while show the leading
transgender health organization in the
world has finally released its new
guidelines recommending medical and
surgical transition for kids also
recommending
that in some cases they go around the
parents if parents aren't affirming
enough parental consent is now optional
says wpath also in one of the best
stories of the year governor ron
desantis ships plane loads of illegals
to the sanctuary city of martha's
vineyard we'll find out how this is just
like the holocaust according to the left
and the treasury secretary says that the
irs is the foundation of our country in
our daily cancellation a fat activist on
twitter twitter says that she's only fat
because of white people how does she
connect those dots we'll find out about
that and much more today on the matt
well show
[Music]
the bite administration has recently
announced its plan to hire 87 000 new
irs agents in 2023 many of whom will be
bearing arms as they hunt for your money
so you need to secure your savings in a
tax sheltered account now and birch gold
can help you do just that birch gold
group helps you hold a gold and silver
and tax sheltered retirement account to
protect you from big government tyranny
plus throughout history gold has always
been your best hedge against inflation
diversified savings can protect you from
downturns in the market if you have a
401k or ira that's underperforming just
text walsh to 989898 and you can convert
that into an ira in precious metals
right now birch gold group has an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews and they
also have thousands of satisfied
customers you can just listen what the
customers have to say and you know
you'll be in good in good hands text
walsh to 98 98 98 and birch gold will
send you a free info kit on diversifying
into gold tax free take the necessary
steps to hedge against inflation today
and protect your hard earned money get
your free info kit by texting walsh to
98 98 98 now
there is no good reason why the opinions
and proclamations of the world
professional association for transgender
health or wpath should matter at all to
anyone the organization was founded in
the late 1970s not by a medical doctor
but by a social social psychologist
named paul allen walker uh walker worked
with john money who as you know if you
heard on this show is the depraved quack
who performed sexual experiments on
young boys causing two of his test
subjects to kill themselves uh walker
for his part who was openly gay lived in
the castro district in san francisco set
up his practice in the same city where
he helped facilitate sex change
surgeries back like in the 60s and 70s
he also had a treatment center quote
unquote for sex offenders but walker
never met someone who wouldn't
be diagnosed with gender dysphoria
according to him i mean he would just
diagnose anyone for example walt heyer
who's a man who detransitioned back in
the early 90s and has been speaking out
against
the gender ideology industry ever since
he tells the story of his initial
consultations with walker in 1981. now
heyer
was abused by his grandmother as a very
young boy if you've heard his story
before you're familiar with it but um he
was just to summarize very briefly
he was forced to dress in girl clothing
as like a four-year-old child by his
by his grandmother and to use the
current phrase in other words he was
sort of socially transitioned into a
girl against his will just because his
grandmother was a
an abusive
psychopath now in his 40s heyer became a
patient of walker and explained this
history of childhood abuse and trauma to
him but he was immediately diagnosed
with gender dysphoria anyway and
recommended for
hormones and surgery so to be clear
walker's recommendation was that haier
should use drugs and surgery to affirm
the false identity that his insane
abusive grandmother created for him when
he was four years old that's the kind of
mental health professional that walker
the founder of wpath was
eventually he died of aids and the
leadership of wpath was passed on to
somebody else which brings us to
today today the president of the
organization is a man named walter
pierre bowman who is a sexologist and
quote unquote trans health specialist
he's on his way out though apparently
and the president-elect of the
organization is marcy bowers who's the
trans uh sex chain surgeon featured in
my film what is a woman
the organization's treasurer is a guy
named lauren schechter who's a plastic
surgeon from chicago
and who also performs gender transitions
on adults and children in fact all the
way down the line from president on down
in this organization you find people who
are not only totally ideologically
invested in the trans agenda
and therefore untrustworthy sources of
information
but even worse they are financially
invested
bowers schechter many of the rest in
leadership and on the board all have
made millions of dollars from the gender
affirmation business
so
now they're in charge of w path and the
more that w path relaxes their
recommendations and guidelines and sort
of opens things up and uh the more of
the population that they can include
as potential patients
and as potential candidates for uh
gender affirmation procedures quote
unquote the more money they personally
make
this is a conflict of interest to say
the least
and yet it has not stopped wpath from
becoming the leading authority
on trans health in the world
not according to me anyway but according
to
uh all the you know major medical
institutions and organizations
it shouldn't matter what they say or
what they recommend but it does because
whatever they declare
is uncritically adopted by every other
major medical organization in the
western world which is what makes their
highly anticipated set of new guidelines
just released this week
unfortunately relevant
christina buttons who's our new and
quite fearless reporter at the daily
wire reports this
quote um the the leading transgender
health association has released its much
anticipated new guidelines one aspect
noticeably different from previous
editions is that the explicitly stated
minimal age recommendations for minors
to have to obtain puberty blockers
cross-sex hormones and surgeries have
been removed
now to uh state the obvious here or to
restate
that means that there is now
no official minimum age recommendation
for any gender transition procedure
so continuing
the new guidance also suggests that if
parents do not affirm their child's
newly chosen identity the state may be
unable to intervene in order to assist
with the child's transition
wpath published its standards of care
8th edition in the international journal
transgender health on september 6 2022 a
correction was published in the same
journal on september 15th which removed
sections pertaining to quote minimal
ages for gender affirming medical and
surgical treatments for adolescents
a confidential draft of the
edition was released for public review
in december 2021
that lowered the recommended minimum age
for minors to obtain cross-sex hormones
which caused permanent changes to the
body from 16 to 14 and then also
irreversible chest face and genital
surgeries to 15 16 and 17 respectively
little has changed from the early draft
and while wpath no longer provides
explicit minimum age recommendations in
their latest official guidelines a close
reading of the text finds that age
suggestions
are woven into the text so
before we read a little bit more of this
there are basically two ways to
potentially interpret
wpath's decision to remove the explicit
minimum age recommendations
from the text one
is that they don't want there to be any
minimum age you know they want to open
the door for any procedure at any age we
heard from a gender surgeon in a clip
last week
that he doesn't recognize any minimum
age at all for any form of medical
intervention we heard that explicitly
or you might theorize that wpath removed
some of these minimum age guidelines or
at least made them harder to find in the
text
made them a little bit less clear
because they don't want people to know
that these things are being done to kids
as young as 14.
i mean they've been talking openly about
doing these things to kids for many
years but now
some of us are paying attention and
drawing attention to it and they don't
want that
which is the same reason why children's
hospitals and other clinics around the
country have been frantically removing
this information from their website any
mention of performing any sort of
procedures on kids that we're moving
from website not because they don't do
it anymore but because they don't want
us to notice it they don't want to give
us something really simple that we can
point to and say oh you see
they're trying to make it harder for
critics to expose what's going on rather
than laying it all out plainly in a
document that we can again just point to
and say well there it is
now i tend to think that out of these
two possible explanations maybe there's
truth to both
reading gone uh chapter six on
adolescence in the new guidelines
suggests that cross-sex hormones may be
administered to children as young as 14.
quoting from the document says more
recent guidelines suggest there may be
compelling reasons to initiate um gender
affirming hormone therapy prior to the
age of 16 although there are limited
studies on youth who have initiated
hormones prior to 14 years of age
in the same chapter so you see how they
they have the ages there they make it a
little bit more obscure what they're
actually saying a little bit more
in the same chapter guidance is issued
for chest masculinization surgery
otherwise known as a double mastectomy
which is the removal of healthy breasts
quoting again from the documents that
chest masculinization surgery can be
considered in minors when clinically and
developmentally appropriate as
determined by a multi-disciplinary team
experienced in adolescent and gender
development though no precise age is
indicated most pediatric gender clinics
will perform double mastectomy surgeries
on uh 15 year olds guidance on
vaginoplasties the creation of a
pseudo-vagina using existing genital
tissue indicates that they may be
obtained as a minor as well quoting
again from the document while the sample
sizes are small these studies suggest
there may be a benefit for some
adolescents to having these procedures
performed before the age of 18 reads the
guidelines
now
keep in mind again
that younger children
[Music]
undergoing gender transition means
millions of more dollars in the pockets
of the very people who are making these
recommendations
now we should know that wpath does at
least have one form of genital
mutilation which it uh does not yet
recommend for kids quote the only
general surgery it seems the wpath is
comfortable setting an age
recommendation for is phalloplasty which
creates a penis-like phallus from skin
grafts taken elsewhere in the body
the document says given the complexity
of phalloplasty and current high rates
of complications in comparison to other
gender affirming surgical treatments it
is not recommended that this surgery be
considered in youth under 18 at this
time
the at this time qualifier is rather
glaring and conspicuous
and so is this part
reading from the document
we recommend when gender affirming
medical or surgical treatments are
indicated for adolescents healthcare
professionals working with transgender
and gender diverse adolescents involve
parents or guardians in the assessment
and treatment process unless their
involvement is determined to be harmful
to the adolescent or not feasible
helping youth and parents slash
caregivers work together on important
gender care decisions is a primary goal
however in some cases parents and
caregivers may be too rejecting of their
adolescent child and their child's
gender needs to be part of the clinical
evaluation process in these situations
youth may require the engagement of
larger systems of advocacy and support
to move forward with the necessary
support and care
now this statement
from wpath will be and has been reported
as wpath
recommending parental consent
oh they're being responsible they're
saying that there should be parental
consent
but they're actually doing the opposite
which is quite obvious when you read it
what they're saying is that parental
consent matters
if the parent says yes
if the parent says no their opinion
doesn't matter
so you only get consent if the consent
if there is consent consent only matters
if you say yes
which is to say
that your consent doesn't matter your
opinion doesn't matter at all in either
case
the medical establishment is saying to
the parents here we're going to do what
we want to your kids and we'll get the
state involved if we have to
and you can give us your approval and
we'll do it
or you can disapprove and we'll still do
it
what this means is that the approval is
irrelevant and symbolic at best
the parents are cut out of the equation
and consent is deferred not to the child
who cannot actually consent
but to the very surgeons and doctors who
are financially invested
in transitioning as many people as they
can
as young as they can
and as fast as they can
that's what so much of this is about
now we know that they are
um
rabid ideologues that are in the gender
transition industry and they're at wpath
and they're
as i said ideologically invested in this
um they're they're religious fanatics
and they want to induct as many people
as they can into their cult and that's
what's driving a lot of it but we can't
overlook the fact that they're also just
scam artists
trying to make a buck or two or two
billion
that's what much of this traces back to
let's get to our five headlines
well we know the left has proclaimed an
all-out war on childhood having a will
in place is the least you can do to
protect your kids although there's so
much more you could do you could start
here a will gives you the power to
decide who will raise your kids should
something happen to you and your spouse
without one the state decides and you
don't want that to happen a will is
about protecting your legacy protecting
your finances protecting your children
ensuring your medical decisions are
honored when you're unable to see them
through deciding who will take on the
responsibility of raising your children
or caring for a parent or grandparent a
will may be your only opportunity to
direct important family heirlooms
financial investments and
responsibilities to the proper people in
your life plus it's incredibly easy and
affordable with epic will epic will
bundles your last will living will
healthcare power of attorney hipaa
release and durable financial power of
returning all into one it only costs 119
for a single person to create a will and
when you use promo code walsh you'll
save 10 as well go to epicwheel.com use
promo code walsh to save 10 on epic
wills complete will package you got to
do it now
don't wait that's epic will.com promo
code welsh
this is uh one of my favorite stories of
the year potentially of all time we've
heard about republican governors sending
busloads of illegals to chicago and new
york and other places well ron desantis
i think tops them all with this as
you've probably heard daily wire the the
far left melted down wednesday night in
response to governor ronda sanders
sending two plane fulls of illegal
immigrants to martha's vineyard a
massachusetts island that is home to
wealthy progressives like president
barack obama
uh the uh office of santa's office said
in a statement yes florida can confirm
the two planes with illegal immigrants
that arrived in martha's vineyard today
were part of the state's relocation
program to transport illegal immigrants
to sanctuary destinations states like
massachusetts new york and california
will better facilitate the care of these
individuals who they have invited into
our country by incentivizing illegal
immigration through their designation as
sanctuary states and support for the
bind administration's open border
policies
now
you know this is uh
this is something that you know you
think the left would support especially
if they declared themselves sanctuary
states and also they would be the first
to say that i mean ron desantis is uh
he's uh he's a fascist he's hitler
incarnate in fact they do say that we'll
get that in a second
but and and and florida is a you know a
hell hole you don't want to live there
there's no is it don't say gay you can't
even say the word gay when you're
walking down the street or
a drone will come by and incinerate you
that's how bad it is there texas is even
worse so you think they would be quite
excited about these illegal immigrants
being relocated from those terrible
terrible states and brought to places
that have declared themselves to be
sanctuaries
i mean they say we are a sanctuary come
to us and then as it turns out when uh
the republicans governors take them up
on that and say okay well here you go
here's here here's some people for your
sanctuary
well no not
well we didn't mean we meant uh you know
spiritually we're spiritual we're here
for moral support from a distance
you know we'll give a thumbs up from
that's what we wanted to do that's what
we meant by sanctuary state
um leftist proceeded to erupt with anger
that desantis would send the illegal
immigrants to the island with many
falsely accusing him of human
trafficking or being a literal nazi
former cnn reporter jackie
schechner says the nazis had a
relocation program desantis
communications director actually uses
the word the state's relocation program
oh
well the nazis relocated
people
and this is also being called relocation
yeah i mean you know when i when uh when
the daily wire moved to tennessee
from from los angeles i was living in
pennsylvania at the time
and uh they wanted me to relocate
here to nashville
you know and um
so
i i am also you know i am essentially
the victim of
the holocaust now because of that
because it's relocation
well no obviously see when the nazis
relocated people
um they were relocating jews to ghettos
and then eventually they were being
relocated quote unquote to concentration
camps where they were
slaughtered
in this case we have illegal immigrants
being put on a nice jet and brought to
the wealthiest and nicest neighborhood
in the country
where again they have been told that
we're a sanctuary
this nazi comparison has come up more
than once not surprisingly here's a
conversation with the
documentarian ken burns who's just
making it it's kind of
making a bad bad name for all the rest
of us documentarians in the
documentarian uh community but anywhere
he here he is talking about this uh
connection between ron desantis and
hitler
this is history all of your
documentaries are about history yeah but
all of them also make you think
about where we are exactly and we woke
up to the news this morning that
governor ron desantis of florida sent
two plane loads of migrants uh to
martha's vineyard off the coast of
massachusetts including kids and whatnot
and i'm not saying this is not a one for
one this is not a parallel here in any
way
but it does address some of the same
themes that are part of this documentary
the abstraction of human life it's
basically saying that you can use a
human life that is as valuable as yours
or mine or limbs and to put it in a
position of becoming a political pawn in
somebody's authoritarian game this is
the coming straight out of the
authoritarian playbook this is what's so
uh disturbing about desantis is to use
human beings to weaponize human beings
for a political purpose it's like when
somebody disagrees with him in florida
like the walt disney company he punishes
them this is not the actions of a person
participating in a democratic process in
which there's an exchange of ideas this
is about punishing political enemies
putting on uh shows political shows
political theater and in this case this
is with the lives of human beings and
what's so ironic is these are venezuelan
refugees which de santa should be
supporting because they're trying to
flee the the corruption of a left-wing
government and all of the pain there and
so this the the level of cynicism is
beyond that and and what we find in all
our films is that the themes that we
engage in the past are
good enough shut up ken we got it
um uh
where to even begin
okay even if it was true that ron
desantis is using the illegal immigrants
as quote political pawns
which to accuse him of that is to admit
that the whole sanctuary state thing was
was was you know a mirage it was not
serious
i mean this is they're only political
pawns if there's if the sanctuary state
because that's what that's
sending them to a sanctuary state so
what they're saying is that yeah he's he
is calling um you know the bluff of uh
you know massachusetts new york that's
what these republican governors are in
there they're calling the bluff of these
other states who claim to be sanctuary
states
um
but they're not admitting that
explicitly
but even if that's true they use them as
political pawns is that what the that's
what the holocaust was
that's what the holocaust was all about
was using what jews as political pawns
that's it
no i think the issue with the holocaust
was the mass murder
okay so it's it's something quite beyond
being used as a political pawn mass mass
slaughter was the issue there
they also mentions the abstraction of
human life which is a good phrase
actually it's a useful phrase
uh and that is happening in our culture
but who's doing that exactly
the abstraction of human life what does
that mean i guess it means making human
life abstract
um
kind of obscuring it making it this kind
of abstract concept
well where is that going on
that's that's going on with it in the
womb that's the pro-abortion side that's
the left as always as always when they
accuse someone of doing something it's
because they themselves are doing it
every single time it's like a hundred
percent of the time that's the case
certainly the case here
that's exactly what they're doing here
they are the ones that are saying well i
don't know
when does human life begin nobody knows
we can't even define it
you know we know we can stump them with
what is a woman you could also stop them
by asking what is human life they can't
define they want to find it so who's
who's engaging in the abstraction here
we're not making human life abstract we
can give you a definition we tell
exactly what it is and when it starts
the white house also was uh on the scene
to denounce
this unethical move by ron desantis
let's listen to that
on what you call this political stunt
with the asylum seekers
let's specifically get into the
locations
martha's vineyard
the naval observatory can you talk to
the issue of you said boston
it's an island that they sent
the asylum seekers to an island that um
is known to be
in some instances of democratic haven
uh former presidents former democratic
presidents vacation there own homes etc
could you speak to that as well as the
naval observatory
what i could say and i've been very
clear
it is a political stunt
that's what we're seeing from governor
governors republican governors in in
particular and um
it is a cruel inhumane
way of treating uh people who are
fleeing communism
uh people who are who are uh and we're
not just talking about people we're
talking about children we're talking
about families uh who are promised a
home promised a job put on a bus
and uh you know driven to a place that
they do not know
and it is a cruel thing to do according
to local reports governor ron desantis
sent a hired videographer on the plane
to massachusetts
to order to capture footage of them
being dropped off remember there were
children on this plane so i cannot speak
to uh anything outside of what we're
seeing right i i
you know i i'll take that inhumane
treatment a free private jet ride to
martha's vineyard you know i'll take
that
um
being used as a political pawn she says
that oh they're being put on buses and
shipped to a place they don't know yeah
what does that remind you of i mean it
reminds you of the of the illegal
immigration epidemic that's been ongoing
for decades that's exactly the problem
that's what these these uh governors
you know in border states and governors
down south have been saying what
conservatives in general have been
saying for years
is that when you open up the border and
you invite people in and you start
talking about how you're a sanctuary
city a sanctuary state whatever
this is what you end up with
so once again accusing people of doing
exactly what they're doing they're the
ones who have for decades been using
illegal immigrants as political pawns
um
inviting them in to these red states
they don't want to have to deal with
themselves would invite them into the
red states
but what they're actually having a
problem with what they're really saying
is well how dare you use illegal
immigrants as political pawns only we're
supposed to do that we're the ones that
are that that's our thing not yours
it's like a form of plagiarism
essentially is what they're accusing ron
santos of
but really it's the reaction from some
of the local leaders themselves that's
really telling here's the um homeless
shelter coordinator
in martha's vineyard
and here's what she had to say about
this
so what are the most difficult
challenges right now the difficult
challenges are
uh
we have at some point in time they have
to move from here to somewhere else
right we cannot we don't have the
services
to take care of 50 immigrants
and we certainly don't have housing
we're in a housing crisis as we are on
this island and so
we don't we can't house everyone here
that lives here and works here we don't
have housing for 50 more people
eventually you have to pick them up and
move them somewhere else we can't take
care of the mirror we don't have a
housing it's a crisis so so uh 50
illegal immigrants in martha's vineyard
is a crisis a humanitarian crisis what's
what they've been calling it a
humanitarian crisis well what is
thousands of illegal immigrants every
single day being funneled into these
border towns and border states what do
you call that
um
well we should see again the left left
likes diversity in theory but they
certainly don't want to have to actually
confront it in reality
and this also goes to show
that
the most compassionate and humane border
policy
is one that deters people from coming
here to begin with
because once you have the flood of
illegal immigrants coming into the
country there are no good answers when
they're here there's no good answers and
when you have this unchecked tide coming
in every single day there are no good
answers um there are right answers but
there aren't any like no matter
every answer is difficult
and
the only way to stop that is to deter
people from coming here in the first
place
yeah it's not shipping them off it'd be
better if if uh ron sanchez didn't have
to do that it'd be better if greg abbott
didn't have to ship illegals up to
sanctuary
cities and sanctuary states that'd be
better
but they're here because the border's
not secure
so why can't we all agree that that
actually the best thing is for them not
to come to begin with and how do you
stop them from coming well you secure
the border border obviously
but it also means that you again you
have to have a policy that deters people
from coming which means when they come
you know you have to be very strict
and even seemingly unkind
like you come here you shut the border
down people come doesn't matter how far
they've been traveling you turn them
around and say you can't come in here go
away
it seems really upsetting to people and
it does seem unkind and uncharitable but
that is actually the most charitable and
compassionate thing
if you want to avoid this humanitarian
crisis
in martha's vineyard
which is the only place the left cares
about if it's a martha vineyard they
care about they don't care about the
humanitarian crisis that's been ongoing
for decades in texas
you really want to avoid a humanitarian
crisis then that's what you do you shut
the border down
and you are strict
about it
and unwavering
and you're not allowed to come here
illegally if you come here we will send
you away and that's it
all right don lemon
uh has been demoted essentially not
essentially i mean he's been we know
that um
at cnn they're kind of scrambling and
trying to figure out what's wrong with
their ratings i mean what's wrong with
rings is nobody wants to watch cnn so um
they got we know they got rid of brian
stelter they got rid of uh
chris cuomo a while ago and they're
revamping their prime time lineup
they're taking don lemon and they're
kicking them down to the morning show
and they're demoting them they're taking
them out of prime time putting them
somewhere that's not prime time
but um this is kind of embarrassing for
him he uh
rather than just kind of going quietly
on his show last night he's defending
himself
we just talked about the problem of like
getting defensive he's defending himself
against the claim that he was demoted
and here's how that went
i was presented with an opportunity that
i can't pass up at this network and we
have a new boss who um
is a morning show impresario
and he wants a morning show that will
kick off the editorial direction of the
network every single day and i am
honored that he asked me to do it and
for all of those are out there saying oh
he moved me and without my
he asked me and i said yes i could have
said no this is my show i have a
contract for this show i decided that i
would take him up on that and take this
journey with him so this is not someone
moving me and by the way this is not
someone saying you must move to the
right don lemon you must not be so um
give so much of your perspective none of
that has happened all of that is fodder
for twitter which is not real so stop it
i was not demoted none of that this is
an opportunity this is a promotion this
is this is um
an opportunity for me to create
something around me and i get to work
with two great ladies who you know poppy
harlow who i've known for more than a
decade i went to her wedding in slovenia
i know her children i know her husband
and caitlyn collins same thing we've
been friends since caitlyn has been at
the network
this i was not demoted i wasn't
uh i love the phrase there i i i decided
to take this journey with him
so your boss calls you in
and says uh yeah we're kicking you down
a few notches here you're not you're not
performing well
you know we're gonna give you a pay cut
a demotion
okay i'll take this journey with you
let's go hand in hand on this journey
um first of all nobody volunteers for to
do the morning show
especially not from prime time
like you're gonna you really you want to
get up at 3 30 in the morning
and do it and do a show it's what you
really want instead of being in prime
time i doubt it
but you also notice he his his near
admission of bias not that we need him
to admit it we already know but
he almost admits it
he says um
he says oh no it's it they didn't come
to me and say move to the right stop
being and then he stops himself
you know stop giving my perspective so
he almost said they didn't tell me move
to the right stop being so liberal
and then he stopped himself
again not that we needed his admission
but even so
all right maybe uh let's play one other
clip this is the
uh treasury secretary janet yellen
waxing poetically about the irs
today i want to spend some time
discussing how the new irs funding in
the inflation reduction act will make
these types of investments possible as
well as its impact on the american
economy but first
i want to begin by speaking about the
irs itself
as our nation's revenue collection
agency
the irs is a foundation of our
government and our society
the irs collects 96 percent of the
revenue that funds the federal
government
that supports our priorities from
national security to infrastructure to
social security
it's also one of the very few parts of
the federal government that touches
nearly every american household
irs employees are known
for their extraordinary dedication to
public service
they have always served with distinction
but over the past couple of years the
employees of the irs have been called to
step
and further
to serve the american people
serve the american people with audits
that's what you we're getting served
with
by the way i don't mean this in a bad
way i really don't i don't mean this is
an insult but um
every time i see janet yellen doesn't
she look a little bit like the albino
who works in the torture chamber in the
princess bride
uh we could put up a split screen maybe
of that i don't know i you know again
it's not it's quite a handsome guy so no
i don't mean that's an insult i just
i don't know if they've found that it
would make sense
to find that person works at a torture
chamber um what do they call that in the
film the pit of despair
so put that person who runs a pit of
despair runs the irs you know there is a
connection there anyway um the irs
is the foundation of the united
states uh you you laugh at that but it's
actually it's just an outrageous
claim and it's another although it's an
overused term it's quite orwellian this
rewrite of history
i mean america was founded
on it on a on a tax revolt i mean it was
it was founded by people who revolted
rebelled
would started killing people because of
taxes and so now
the foundation of the country is that
the
revenue collection
agency
which by the way didn't even exist
um for the first century plus of the of
the of the country's existence
and now that it serves as our foundation
which there's a lot of truth to that
from her perspective from the from the
perspective of the powers that be here
the regime that is how they see it
the irs is utterly foundational
which uh probably tells you everything
you need to know let's get now to the
comment section
[Music]
uh you know one of the great things
about being a parent is that it provides
you with many occasions to learn empathy
and i need a lot of practice in that
regard as you know so it's a good thing
and um and the reason is that your
children will get upset about the
dumbest things all the time and this
this this holds true at every age by the
way every stage of childhood and your
job is to try to understand where
they're coming from and to not be
dismissive because yeah you don't want
to uh
if they're if they're overreacting to
something you don't want to encourage it
but at the same time you can't always be
dismissive and you have to try to sort
of understand where they're coming from
so last night
i put the kids down for bed and i went
upstairs about 30 minutes later my son
my five-year-old
is sitting in his bed sobbing
uncontrollably and i go in and ask him
what's wrong and he says that he's
scared and i ask him why he's scared and
he says he's scared because his toys
come to life at night while he's
sleeping and he's worried about that
which admittedly i mean i would be
worried about that too if that was
happening but i tried to explain to him
it's not happening um toys don't
actually come to life that's just for
the movies and tv shows it's not real
it's not physically possible but i made
it worse because at one point he says
well
i know the toys when they come to life
they can't touch humans they can't
attack humans but it's still scary
that's what he said to me my son by the
way never uses the word person or people
he only ever says humans for some reason
so if we're in the mall or something and
there's a lot of people there he'll say
he'll say uh there are a lot of humans
in here
or did you see that human driving that
car
and it makes sense it's a perfectly
valid way of saying it just you never
realize how weird some phrasing sounds
until you hear it out loud anyway so he
says that the toys come to life
but they don't touch humans
and then i say
well how do you know they can't touch
you
and he says wait so they can they can
attack me and i said no i didn't mean it
like that i'm just wondering where
you're getting information is this very
specific information you have i want to
know where you got it from
and he has like this whole mythology
that he's built up i said did you get
this from toy story what are we talking
about let me know so we can i can engage
with you a little bit in this
conversation and i guess he just came up
with it in his head and was immediately
convinced of its validity and at another
point i'm still trying to convince him
this went on for like a while this
conversation about about the toys coming
to life
and and uh and
and he goes and i say well they no they
don't keep trying to tell they don't
come to life
and he says
well have you ever seen toys
not come to life when you're sleeping
and stop and think about that for a
second have i seen toys
not come to life
when i'm sleeping
uh
i said no i guess i haven't seen that
well you see so you don't know
anyway so maybe he's right maybe they do
come to life i i guess i really don't
know i just
my whole concept of reality broke down
all right this is melanie wilde says i
love it when the media takes your
hilarious dry humor so literal um
honestly nobody could say conservatives
aren't funny because matt gets me
rolling daily thanks man i don't know
what you're talking about what
there was no joking on yesterday's show
especially it was one of my most serious
shows
i don't even know what you're referring
to
um
cameron says this was hands down without
a doubt the greatest opening monologue
in admittedly the short history of
podcasting why thank you for that
and i would also say probably one of the
most important monologues if i do say so
myself
uh
genevieve says your rant about starbucks
baristas made me howl with laughter my
ex-best friend once i was serious about
that too so what do you guys laugh about
everything for everything was serious
especially the stuff about baristas
my ex-best friend once yelled at me
driving in the middle of chicago traffic
telling me her job as a starbucks
barista was a career that she plans to
grow into
this was a response to me trying to help
her find a job with her college degree
that she had received over a year ago a
degree which was in uh you guessed it
photography needless to say our
friendship didn't last much longer after
that
well i'm sure your friend was quite
annoying and so i wouldn't mourn the
fact that she's gone but i would say
like i i don't
i wouldn't uh begrudge anyone or just
dissuade or try to discourage anyone who
is in a customer service job and says
that they see it as a career it can be
actually now like
being a you know working the drive
through at starbucks
is not in itself a career hopefully
you're not doing that for 20 years
but if you see that as a stepping stone
and you kind of want to stay in the
customer service world and you want to
work up to being a manager and then
eventually you got your own uh you have
your own location that you're running
you know you work you work your way up
that way i think that's perfectly
admirable and noble and that's that's a
career path that many people follow i
guess that's great
but that means that's all the more
reason why if you see it that way
then when you're there you're going to
be working as hard as you can putting in
the extra effort you're not going to be
recording tick tocks complaining about
your job you're not going to be focusing
on all the things you hate so much and
trying to avoid you know getting mad
when people
order complicated drinks that make you
work harder because you're there and you
see this as an opportunity
so i actually you know i encourage
people to have that attitude actually
um
let's see
uh ssg emiratus says i saw a headline
that read that you had a meltdown over
the little mermaid i laughed so hard at
you having a meltdown your excellent
response was a classic responsible
knowledgeable version of a matt walsh
meltdown good for you i did read there
have been many headlines like that
actually because the media is still
talking about this by the way and now
people are sending me tick so tick tock
has gotten in on the action maybe we'll
play some of those videos next week i
don't know as we continue the mermaid
conversation into um
just indefinitely but so they're you
know there's more reporting on it and
yeah that has
seemed to be the most common
characterization
of our initial conversation about
translucent mermaids is that they're
saying it was a meltdown i don't know a
meltdown about it
because yeah everyone knows
uh this is what people know this about
me that's my personality i'm overly
emotional i get very excited easily
uh overly enthusiastic that's
i i admit that's one of my great
greatest flaws
right now over at dailywire.com shop
they're running an inflation reduction
event in response to the bite
administration's feeble attempt to
magically reduce inflation by spending
more money use code 40 at checkout for
40 off anything in the inflation
reduction collection including a lot of
the sweet baby gang's greatest hits and
even my beloved magnum opus johnny the
walrus is also there
once you're done stuffing your car with
sale items you can head over to my swag
shack and get the perfect companion to
my book which is the official johnny the
walrus plushie uh we're doing the walrus
plug yet again we are i thought they
might actually do a shop read for
something mildly less traumatizing like
a shirt emblazoned with my bearded face
on the body of an infant
or you know what actually we should have
a we do need some kind of
translucent mermaid shirt anyway we'll
talk about we don't have that yeah we'll
we'll talk about it
i still don't have my own walrus that's
the point but you my sweet babies can so
head over to dailywire.com shop to get
yours today also recently the daily wire
was uh cc'd on an email from a harry
raisers customer who was canceling their
subscription and switching to jeremy's
this is what he wrote
quote dear harry's i have used and
enjoyed your razors for five years now
and even have a personalized harry's
handle however i was disappointed to
learn of the circumstances in which your
company disassociated from the daily
wire as such i am not giving any more of
my money to you as i think jeremy
jeremy's razors dot com could find more
uses aligned with the values i hold
there i will add that i am a resident of
the uk and jeremy's does not currently
ship outside of the usa therefore i'm
arranging to have my jeremy subscription
sent to my family in the usa where it
will then be sent at an additional cost
to me this is a small price i'm willing
to pay to expressly support those who
stand against woke bullying
signed king charles iii
uh no this email was not written by
britain's new sovereign but the
understandably frustrated citizen who
did was certainly right about one thing
jeremy can find more uses for your money
aligned with values that you hold dear
and frankly razors are just to start we
enjoy receiving this email so much that
we're encouraging you to do the same
when you subscribe to jeremy's razors
see see us on your own breakup email
with harry's or gillette and maybe we'll
read it on the show so just send it to
reviews jeremy's razors dot com
stop giving your money to what
corporations that hate you give it to
jeremy instead go to jeremy's razors dot
com today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we check in with the fat community
over at tick tock a realm that we may
call
thick talk that's actually my producer
sean's joke uh now as the host of the
show it's my god-given right to steal
the joke without credit i can steal any
joke i hear around here because it's
mine that's the way it goes but i've
decided to forego that privilege and
give credit where it's due
in this case so there it is thick talk
anyway we'll start with one recent viral
video from a fat activist and then
perhaps we'll continue down the thick
talk rabbit hole
and see what else we may find here it is
i'm going to prove to you why white
people are the reason i'm fat today
if white people didn't go looking for
spices then a various sea routes to
indian subcontinent and africa and other
places of the world would not get
discovered
and if they didn't get discovered then
east india company would never come to
indian subcontinent
and if they didn't come
then the fertility of the land would not
get destroyed because they forced us to
cultivate tobacco and dies in opioid
things like that and that destroyed the
fertility of my country
and then if that didn't happen and if
they didn't exploit and extract
resources until my ancestors were left
with nothing to eat
we wouldn't move to this grain heavy
very little nutritious diet that we have
today
also if white people didn't come to the
indian subcontinent then my ancestors
would not go through 50
small medium large famines
in
a period of 200 years
that's a lot
and in 1943
nearly 3 million people would not have
died due to starvation and malnutrition
and if that didn't happen
then this entire
place
and the people of this place would not
adapt to survive on lower calories
okay i didn't realize that was a 45
minute clip uh but it's a fun game i
have to admit it's like it's like the
self-victimizing version of seven
degrees of kevin bacon just take some
negative aspect of yourself that you
don't want to take responsibility for
and then find a way to cast the blame as
far away from yourself as possible i can
do this too you know for instance i tend
to be impatient and at times
ill-tempered i admit it's not my fault
though it can actually be traced
directly back to alexander the great's
invasion of persia in 334 bc
i'll need to do some research on
wikipedia to connect all the dots but
i'm sure there's a way to do it
actually in this woman's case you might
compare it more to a sort of um it's
sort of like a butterfly effect but for
fatness
so a butterfly flaps its wing 700 miles
away sets off a chain of causation
that eventually ends with this girl
eating a cheeseburger
although here in a rather extraordinary
feat of deflection she has punted
responsibility actually out of this
century halfway across the previous
millennium
imagine that the mental gymnastics
required to be in the process of
devouring
like a cinnabon while thinking to
yourself this is all vasco de gama's
fault damn you vasco
meanwhile there is as always
an obvious contradiction at work here on
the one hand we're told that fat is
beautiful fat is good fat is healthy fat
is desirable
on the other hand
it's also very important for us to
believe that fat people are fat through
no fault of their own so it's like
this is good
but it's not my fault
well if it's beautiful and good then why
would you not want to take credit for it
in fact if white people made this girl
fat then shouldn't she be thanking us
given that fat is beautiful we made you
beautiful you're welcome
which is it is my question you have to
choose pick a lane
either it's bad and it's not my fault
or it's good in which case the blame
game makes no sense
let's watch the next one
fat shaming and skinny shaming are the
same actually no they're not fat people
are denied jobs proper medical care
health insurance they're paid less they
don't have equal access to clothing
travel many public spaces even the body
mass index the way that it discriminates
against women especially women of color
it was created for and based around
white men like phaphobia is literally
rooted in anti-blackness it's rooted in
racism and sexism skinny shaming is not
how many times have you seen marketing
campaigns that are labeled get fat quick
finally add those stubborn 30 pounds
show me where all the weight gain
industries are show me all the damaging
messages that say that skinny equals
unworthy life or skinny equals ugly when
is the last time that you've been
penalized financially when an aircraft
seed had to be accommodated to your
smaller body when is the last time
you've walked into a doctor's office and
after they weighed you stop listening to
what you were actually there for and
told you to just gain weight because it
will fix everything fat people endure
all of that and more skinny people do
not face employment discrimination or
medical discrimination the world was
designed for you peter burger is just
not comparable to systemic abuse and
oppression
i mean she's absolutely right you know
fat shaming and skinny shaming are not
the same because if you're shaming
somebody for being skinny
then you're shaming them for a healthy
physique provided that they aren't you
know real thin
if you're shaving them for being fat
you're shaming them for being in an
unhealthy and destructive physical state
you really shouldn't be walking up to
people and shaming them for their
appearance in either case but it is
without question worse to shame a good
thing than it is to shame a bad thing
but my favorite part of this clip is her
list of oppressions and persecutions
that fat people face she says fat people
don't have equal access to clothing
which is an interesting way of putting
it so if i gorge myself during
thanksgiving and put on five pounds in
one weekend i can then complain that i
don't have equal access to my own pants
anymore
yet
contrary to the way she phrases it there
is no law preventing fat people from
wearing clothing
i mean incidentally this i was this is
actually news that someone should
probably share with lizzo like you know
you can you're allowed to wear clothes
just so you know
by the way
the reason
there aren't advertisements telling
people how to add pounds she says why
are there any average there's no ads
don't be able to put on pounds
well the reason for that is that number
one you don't want to add pounds right
it's unhealthy but also nobody needs
help doing that
putting on weight is easy and fun and
and often delicious you just make a tray
of brownies that's all it takes
there's no further assistance required
so that's why you don't find that
let's check out one more
i'm gonna be real with y'all i am really
sick and tired of skinny is coming on
this app and trying to compare fat
phobia to getting called a door once
that's called body shaming and it
literally happens to every single person
on the planet at least once it's not a
systemic issue
girl i went to my doctor when i got
diagnosed with severe depression and she
dead ass looked at me and said lose some
weight and break up with your boyfriend
i was in school today thinking about
where i wanted to go for off-campus
lunch and i started looking up
restaurant menus and realized that i
didn't want to linger on the tab too
long in case somebody looked over the
fat girl's laptop seeing where she
wanted to go for lunch and judging me
for it i can't walk into a 7-eleven and
order a slurpee and some skittles
because i'm afraid that when i put them
down on the counter like a skinny person
could do with no problem somebody's
gonna judge me for it i've applied to a
job at a restaurant and heard somebody
say how they're not gonna hire me
because they think i'm fat enough to eat
all the food i'm terrified to be seen
eating in my car eating alone y'all got
insulted once and ran with it
this is what the youth of today are
spending their energy on this is what
they're arguing these are the subjects
they're discussing what's worse fat
shaming or skinny shaming oh my god
okay let's go through a few things here
i would absolutely
absolutely judge you
if you were buying a slurpee and
skittles at the same time i mean fat or
skinny if i see someone washing down
skittles with a slurpee yes i'm going to
make some judgments about that person
that's disgusting and you would deserve
to be judged for it absolutely you
deserve judgment in fact if someone
walked up to you to your face and made
fun of you for buying slow business
skills at the same time you would
deserve that it'd be good it'd be a
wake-up call for you that's like an
intervention
guess what you don't get to be free of
the world's judgment here's newt's flash
for everybody watching right now you
don't get to be free of the world's
judgment you don't nobody does you are
being judged all the time all the time
people look at us and observe our
behavior and make judgments that's
sometimes the judgments are bad
sometimes they're good sometimes they're
neutral this is just what it means to
live in a society among other rational
creatures you can accept that and move
on with your life or you can sit around
crying about i'm being i'm being judged
yes you are
okay we've established that live your
life now
or just stay huddled in a corner in the
fetal position stop judging me
well you've chosen the latter i suppose
and now you're on tick tock like i i
can't i can't even freebase pixie stix
behind the dumpster at 7-eleven without
being judged
of course you can
nor should such behavior be free of
judgment
also you most certainly were not turned
down for a job at a restaurant because
the interviewer said you'd eat all the
food okay that did that just didn't
happen i i it absolutely 100 did not
happen
um however
did a doctor actually tell you that the
cure for depression is to break up with
your loser boyfriend and shed a few
pounds i hope so because that's actually
fantastic advice i wish more doctors
would help their patients adjust their
lifestyles before writing prescriptions
you had a good doctor who cared about
your health which is why i assume you
never went back to him again all in all
if these experiences as you described
them actually all happened and were
upsetting to you there is a solution
it's a solution totally within your
power you can lose weight it won't be
easy but you can do it it is possible i
know from experience that there is a
correlation between diet lifestyle and
weight we all know this from experience
this is the point the fat activists the
fativists seem to always miss
you can't lie to the rest of us about
this issue you can't pretend that you
have nothing to do with your own
waistline
all of us have experienced putting on
weight
because we ate too much and didn't get
enough exercise all of us in the modern
world have experienced that
we know that's how it works we also know
that it's difficult it takes
self-control to practice dietary
discipline
and we know that's why you don't want to
do it not because you're oppressed or
the victim of white supremacy it's just
it's hard and you don't want to do
something that's hard we've all been
there
to one degree or another
which is why
you would actually have our sympathy if
you just said
i know i can get healthy but it's really
hard and so i'm struggling
you could just say that that's a
statement i totally sympathize with
because whether it's weight or something
else we all have things about ourselves
that we don't like or we want to improve
you know but but we have trouble
improving those things because it's hard
it's hard to improve something about
yourself it doesn't matter what it is
and we all have flaws and so if your
flaw is that you tend to over overeat
and you don't get enough exercise and so
you put on weight that's a flaw it is a
flaw you're not the only one in the
world with flaws we all have them and
you could rightly point out that we all
have flaws that's true
but when you make your flaw into a cause
right into a a banner that you march
under into and you want to you try to
convince the world that your flaw is
actually a virtue
well now you've made it an issue we have
to talk about
and that's on you
if you would just admit that it's a flaw
that you do have control over then then
it's a whole it's an entirely different
situation
you know and and
for the rest of us with our flaws we
have them not because uh and we have
trouble solving them not because we
can't solve them or it's impossible or
because it's all the fault of spice
traders in the 1500s
we can control ourselves but it's
difficult and we have trouble doing
difficult things everyone does that's
why we call them difficult
that's something that we can all as
humans relate to and sympathize with and
we can commiserate with each other about
that
we can also support each other and help
each other
but you can't really have anyone's
support or anyone's help or even
sympathy if you refuse to be accountable
for your own choices
as long as you insist on blaming
everything and everyone by yourself
you'll never get over the hurdle you'll
be stuck with the burden forever while
trying to convince yourself that you're
happy with it but you know better you're
not
and that is why
these fat activists
on tick tock are today unfortunately i
must say canceled on this flannel friday
which by the way i can't believe what
the whole show without saying happy
final friday well there it is hope
you're wearing your own flannels as we
move into the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you on uh
monday godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you